you want to hear the kicker oh my gosh
we have heard now
for two months no voter fraud in 2020
no election questions if you dare
question the election you're an
insurrectionist
you're a traitor murderer rapist you
need to be de-platformed you need to be
kicked off of
the air you need to be kicked out of
polite society
so there's a hotly contested
congressional race in new york right now
this is in new york's 22nd
it's a race between anthony brendacy and
claudia tenney who i actually happen to
know from new york politics
so claudia tenney had to see it then
brendacy wins it now looks like tenny's
going to win it again because brenda see
the democrat is just behind
the democrats are alleging voter fraud
specifically they're alleging that the
voting machines
are throwing the election to the
republican and demanding
a recount these candidates are separated
by 122 ballots
and the democrats while they are saying
that any questioning of
voter integrity and in particular any
questions of voting machines
you can have billion-dollar lawsuits
over voting machine fraud claims well
while they're saying that those are
completely illegitimate and you
basically need to be banished to a far
away island if you bring them up
they're making the same claims
themselves
because they always do this sort of
thing and it just reminds me
of these squishy republicans who
follow the democrats line here they say
oh no we have to agree with the
democrats we have to
we can't we can't bring up the question
of fraud that's wrong we can't do that
we got to play by the rules here
democrats don't believe that they're
they're making the same claims when it
suits their
purposes republicans just
don't get it they think that democrats
are being on the level when they are
opposing these claims of voter fraud
right when
when we're talking about voter fraud in
the 2020 election
some people are making these very very
extreme claims
some might say outlandish claims about
mass fraud in the machines and the cia's
involved and it's in
germany and it's who knows there's space
aliens involved right you
there are there are extreme claims but
then there are the claims that are right
before our very eyes which are
undeniable namely democratic election
officials in pennsylvania
broke the law they violated the state
constitution which clearly prohibits
widespread mail-in ballots
how about the election poll watchers who
were sent home
illegitimately republican watchers sent
home in philadelphia
how about those videos we saw of of
election officials putting cardboard in
the windows
so that people who were outside couldn't
see what was going on in the counts
how about the the water main break right
the pipe leaking that sent home the
election officials in certain counties
what
all these little things far more
tangible
you can point to them meanwhile
democrats are making more outlandish
claims about voter fraud just in new
york's 22nd
congressional race and there are two
kinds of republicans the republicans who
recognize that the democrats are being
cynical and they're being cheap and that
we should be skeptical
of their efforts to take away election
integrity measures
those are the good tough serious
conservative republicans
and then there are the squishes there
are the squishy republicans
if you enjoyed that video be sure to hit
the subscribe button so everyone waiting
through the wasteland of youtube
knows that we've got the absolute top
content out there
[Music]
you